bruce
wayne
he's the only one we didn't get
but we got the rest of them didn't we
all those slick sleazy funny pricks
god
look at you
your mask is amazing
i wish you could have seen me in mine
isn't it funny
all everyone wants to do is i'll ask you
but they're missing the point
you and i both know
i'm looking at the real you right now
my mask allowed me to be myself
completely
no shea
no limits why did you write me
what do you mean all those cards i told
you
we've been doing this together you're
part of this we didn't do anything
together we did what did we just do i
asked you to bring him in the light and
you did we're such a good team we're not
a team i never could have gotten him out
of there
i'm not physical my strength is up here
i mean i i had all the pieces i had the
answers but i didn't know how to make
them listen you gave me that i gave you
nothing you showed me what was possible
you showed me all it takes is fear and a
little focused violence you inspired me
you're out of your goddamn mind
what this is all in your head you're
sick
twisted how can you say that you think
you'll be remembered you're a pathetic
psychopath breaking contention you're
gonna die oh no no no no nobody
how this was supposed to go
[Music]
had it all planned out
we were gonna be safe here
we could watch the whole thing together
watch what
everything
it was all there
you mean you didn't figure it out
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
i guess i gave you too much credit what
have you done
what's
black and blue and dead
all over
you
if you think you can stop what's coming
what have you done
[Music]